hey guys thanks so much for checking out
this video this is something that was
totally new for us for me for our
channel so I really hope you guys enjoy
it just a reminder we have graduation
coming up on May 17th this is for anyone
who is graduating in 2020 whether you're
a high school senior or a college senior
or a grad student or middle school
elementary school we want to celebrate
you and your accomplishments so make
sure you click the link down below to
RSVP and get more information about how
you can be featured throughout the
ceremony I look forward to seeing you
hope to see you there okay bye we
brought together seven straight men
[Music]
hello hello hello so this is Bonnie's
voiceover part one take one
I'm Bonnie and I am a director at
Jubilee I've been with jublia for
exactly a year now and I've directed I
think close to 20 videos that's me as
video creators and directors we put a
ton of weight on the comments section of
our videos there can be thousands of
amazing comments but the one critical
hurtful or flat-out hateful one we come
across will be the one that sticks with
us and eats away at us for days weeks
even so I decided to start reaching out
to some of our haters particularly those
who have commented on my own videos to
see if they'd be interested in talking
with me face-to-face neither one of us
really knows who's on the others
and maybe that's the problem again I
know where star like who do I even I
just have to respond to like the meanest
ones all right when I give terrible
people more of a platform to talk about
that disgusting POS seriously Jubilee
what are you doing I guess anything for
the views huh oh okay
I'm literally frozen it-it's been 10
minutes and I have not even commented oh
my god okay let's just go this is the
comment that says I should be fired
garbage everybody leaves the discussion
having not nothing
his description for the videos challenge
conventional thinking my arse well oh
this one is so long and it hurts my
heart I just keep saying this is a
horrific a horrific way to handle the
subject matter like wow that one makes
me want to like cry I'm like lay down
there's something about me - episode
that's like kind of horrifying for me to
tackle something that like means so much
to me and put so much work into it and
then have it be perceived as negligent
is really really hard
it's so weird it like takes you back to
being like a kid where you like want the
bully to like you isn't it so oh now
that I think they're bullying me like I
don't know Mom
oh that one hurt like a lot
and once we sent out all of those
comments and DMS and tweets and emails
we then just kind of had to wait in the
mean time for the sake of my mental
health I wanted to step away from the
eight comments for a bit and ask my
fellow Jubilee directors to chat with me
about their experiences with the
comments section first of all thank you
guys for chatting with me today always
happy to help I just want to talk to you
guys I've like just kind of a casual
conversation about what the comments
section kind of means to us as directors
do you guys have a specific video you
would say it's probably like your worst
experience so when I first started
directing videos I hate like was having
serious digestive issues because of how
nervous I was every time a middle ground
went out and then we put out the
gentrification episode it was like the
fourth comment down it was like these
videos just keep getting worse and worse
yeah I think the ordinance that I did on
every single video there's there's some
people who like is the worst episode
ever
and then actually like it and all that
out is going wrong and I don't know what
you can do right I hold my breath a
little bit and what I'll do is I'll go
comment by comments so it's like a weird
horror movie and it's always a gut punch
then my day is ruined
I feel like this important to read the
comments it's important to critique
people who have a platform because there
are times when we drop the ball you know
like with the spectrum Latino episode
that was one that I was like just
realizing like the negative impact it's
had on people and that was a moment for
me where I realized the power that we
all have as directors with like some of
my more recent middle grounds like when
I did like men's rights versus feminists
and I casted an in so there are so many
dislikes and so many negative comments
on that video but that's like one of the
most proud videos I've ever made and as
an audience member if you're only
willing to watch things
that confirm what you already find to be
true then that's just like the most
boring bone I've ever heard like we
don't watch movies that don't have
villains in them then I started to
wonder who are these people do you guys
kind of like picture someone in your
brain when we get some of these comments
teenage boys
I see teenage girls I see a lot of teen
from young college students gender not
so much I just imagine them like being
on their bed like that screw legs that's
what's also strange it's like people are
there for the comments so true there's
so many times we're like all the
comments are like damn I'm here too
early there's no funny comments and I'm
like wow really like half of your
experience here is just scrolling maybe
not even watching the actual video the
one thing though that we don't really we
experience it to an extent but not that
much it's like the personal comments
then I take it personal even if you're
saying that what I'm doing is causing
harm in the world I take that so
personally that's what people don't get
is they think that we are like sitting
in this super fancy media office like
commanding our army of you know like
interns and minions and then in the
meantime we're like snorting and like
drinking Lacroix only half of that is
true and then they have no idea that we
are sleep deprived usually like scarfing
like yesterday's leftover Panda Express
deep in the credit card debt on the
verge of like existential meltdown the
night before we put together these
shoots when you're making these videos
you feel so powerless most of the time
alright guys well thanks for chatting
with me today I just wanted to give
other directors perspectives alright bye
guys
happy quarantine several days passed and
we hadn't gotten any responses other
than the occasional no so I was still
spending all of my time reading and
replying to as many hate comments as I
could
I don't know I'm like I had a day I
don't think I realized how much doing
this was going to affect my mental
health I'm just filling my brain with
like hate every single day it's like I
know I've said it to several times
jokingly that like this was a bad idea
but like it's actually not a bad idea
for me and some more comments to try and
get to oh oh my god I just got a message
from Tyree that says hold on I think we
got someone oh he's one of the guys I
met me - ugh wait is that thick I knew
it was gonna be this one guys right this
is a horrific way to handle the subject
manner I'm really disappointed by the
negligence of course it's gonna be the
one that I'm like the scared the most
scared of an eye oh my god
oh my god all day long I've just been
like it's not gonna happen
and now it's happening and I have a
whole other world of fears this was not
the one that I wanted and just like that
we were scheduled to talk I was going to
FaceTime my hater in three days
[Music]
after we confirmed my FaceTime with
Bryce we got a couple other responses
including one from the guy critiquing
our series middle-ground only the voice
only and preferably using Google
Hangouts a vaguely spooky okay
this was my first time ever speaking
directly to a hater I had no idea what
to expect
[Music]
hello hi hi this is Bonnie from Jubilee
can i start by asking just like your
name I don't know your name or anything
like that well I go by wool flannel
mm-hmm well I'm curious you know what
sort of prompted the video about our
series of middle ground there's a good
videos I was watching that and you
Americans you're a special kind of over
there so can you just kind of like
explain expand on that a little bit more
this idea of giving people platforms to
speak and something good coming from
that I think that's that's a bit of an
illusion like it can't happen do you not
think that in order to emphasize you
have to like have those human
interactions and conversations I have
empathy for all of these people
understand it but it doesn't make it
less stupid if are we doing videos that
way it would be more of these are why
the Conservatives are wrong or these why
these people are wrong and trying to get
them from that place where they're wrong
and get them to being right yeah I think
one thing that like we struggle with
right is that the Jubilee as a company
doesn't want to like take a side you
know like deem anyone is like right or
wrong or okay it's a noble choice but
there were winners and losers in life
right so you're being willfully ignorant
were
we're being willfully ignorant for not
acknowledging who's wrong or right yes
what do you feel like makes sense like
what do you feel like does work a lot of
time to learn the hard way you need to
be more aggressive you need the ads you
need the attacks through the data we
have on these young people Amazon eBay
Facebook keep having arguments and
fights when we need to do is right there
in front of you for you were you
surprised when I reached out to you
about this
no I suspected you would have wanted you
would have washed there by this point
you know what I know my videos good oh
good
I appreciate you chatting with me and
voicing your opinions and your critiques
I think on some of these we'll have to
agree to disagree
I'll change your mind down the line you
just wouldn't realize it oh you will how
what did you tell me just what data yep
okay all right thanks for chatting with
me today bye bunny bye I mean he said
that were willfully ignorant I don't
know I think it's incorrect to say that
there's no value creating a space for
people to talk the call with wool
flannel made me even more nervous for my
upcoming FaceTime with Bryce my goal had
been to find and get to know the people
on the other side of these comments but
I was starting to realize that maybe
they don't want to be discovered and
maybe they don't want to be known but it
was already too late the next day I had
to get ready for my first face-to-face
conversation with Bryce it was finally
time to come face to face with my hater
[Music]
I did not sleep well last night I'm
supposed to be talking to brace today
I like kept pressing snooze on my alarm
because it was like oh god I don't want
to do this oh god I'm scared
I'm gonna just blow dry my hair and put
makeup on because there's something
about this whole experience but like I
want to be liked by these people so
desperately healthy so it's like 2
o'clock worse was a talk in 30 minutes I
haven't heard anything from him I sent
him like the zoom info and I didn't get
like any confirmation of course like
first I'm so nervous about talking to
this guy and then now I'm like no please
don't abandon me okay I guess I just
wait for a bit my straw is clogged
good messy is okay he just responded and
all I said is you can record period oh
it was eerie getting ready to talk to
Bryce this was a comment that I
considered not responding to in the
first place
I was worried that the video itself and
the subject matter was too close to my
heart and then I was too sensitive and
that I wouldn't be able to kind of look
past all of that and get to know the
person on the other side of the comment
and I think that's what made the whole
experience so daunting I'm fearful that
he's gonna be like a guy who's like
really intelligent who's like ready to
wage war and is gonna just kind of like
spout a bunch of facts at me and be like
trying to win a conversation you know
yummy oh I can hear you oh yeah I'm good
how are you nice to meet you so I wanted
to just kind of start with like general
info I'd love to just like kind of know
a little bit about you before we get
into it yes I just describe myself as
like a really introverted nerd I used to
describe myself as a freelance artist
from West Philadelphia because that's my
passion but now I'm in I do my job I
lived in Philly for like five years
early I lived in West Philly oh yeah oh
yeah I love you Matsui I mean I love
trees that's another really cool thing
about me that's great because you know
what I do do you know my go-to question
is what if you were a tree what kind of
tree would you be
oh oh that's awesome okay so if I were a
tree I would love to be a fig tree
I love that that's a great answer
well cool yeah to start you know and
I'll just kind of explain like why I
think the reason why I had such a strong
reaction to your comment to feel like
I've done a disservice to a community
that I'm trying to represent or give a
voice to I've been ruminating on that
thing for days like I was so depressed
after it came out because I started
seeing like the comments section was
very kind of icky and like yeah okay
well I do want to say something for you
thinking about yeah go ahead
your video was important your video was
good and if you do feel hurt by what I
said I'm sorry that's not my intention
I'm not a troll I'm not trying to hurt
people I've had a difficult life I've
been through physical abuse I dealt with
being sexually assaulted my young so
when I made that comment the reason why
I commented on that one so passionately
is because there were people who had
positions that I did not necessarily
agree with that I thought that was
helpful to see their head space but also
because the things that they said were
attributed to such a sensitive topic if
not being checked immediately and
thoroughly and clearly might have been
harmful people who have negative or or
toxic positions will use that to support
their their inability to be empathetic
and grow their own emotional
intelligence but no your video was great
I wouldn't be commenting that this
thumbs down and unsubscribe so comment
were you like nervous to do this today
to chat with me today yeah a little bit
more in my background I told you had a
rough life
I actually am the person who
abuse for a decade by a caretaker that
eventually threatened my life when I was
young I didn't really get to have the
normal child you know so I I went
through a life where I was bullied
because I've always been kind of
eccentric and a dork so when I went to
school because we're beating me up and I
got beat up when I came home my mother
she's been through a lot too she had
your reasonable cancer that you know
with a urethral cancer nobody is that
longs for organs almost died you know
there's now still working and I'm I'm
sitting here with her you know
supporting each other so it's a lot I've
had a life where you know it's
interrupted where I had challenges so I
don't get nervous about stuff really I
don't know I feel prepared for most
agents oh no I wasn't there that so I
knew what I wanted to convey and what I
cared about
I'm so sorry that those are the
experiences you've had that's like
that's what's so weird is like I'm so
sorry that you had to experience any
sort of pain or violence against you or
trauma to get to this place but you seem
like a very incredible person and like
such an intelligent and kind person so
it's like wow what an awesome person to
be come out of it but I did not I
wouldn't not I'm here I'm alive and it
allows me to connect with people on a
level that wouldn't be able to connect
well I was gonna ask you to do one more
thing that you may not want to do but I
was gonna ask you to what would you mind
reading the comment to me right now oh
sure
so here goes this episode was very hard
to watch and I don't think an issue like
this can be tackled in such a small
sample size or with so little time and I
thought it was a horrific way to handle
this subject matter
sexual assault is far too much serious
variable for people to break down into
black and white all these things and
more should have been strongly expressed
by Jubilee and as a fan of the show
I am extremely disappointed by the
negligence thanks for eating that yeah
yeah that was a really intense I don't I
don't realize how I'm since my words
when I great before I don't talk like
the way out hey thanks for chatting with
me brace it anytime okay well stay safe
out there thank you
hi Brice
I think oh my this is not what I want I
think that like a major thing I took
away from that it's like
today agree with everything hand to say
it's funny I was still nervous leading
up to it and then I was immediately at
ease with him a lot of like elements of
our story are really similar I didn't
tell them that I also like my mom
survived cancer too so like she is a lot
of where my focus has been lately with
like Co bed I wish I had said that to
him
I'm sad I didn't say that to him June
[Music]
Oh
you